look at the circle you see on the board
if we remove a part of the boundary this
is what we get
it's called an arc the arcs length is
basically a part of the circumference of
the circle how can we calculate the
length of an arc it's a curved length
and cannot be measured with a scale
let's understand a few examples consider
the circle divided into two equal parts
they are called semi circles let's
assume that it's radius is R what is the
length of this arc marked in green you
can say that it covers half the boundary
let's write the length of the arc under
the circle so it's length will equal 1/2
multiplied by 2 pi r this tells you that
it's a part of the circumference now
consider a circle divided into four
equal parts like this what will be the
length of this green arc since the
circle is divided into four equal parts
the circumference will also be divided
into four equal parts so the length of
the arc will be 1/4 of the circumference
the length of this arc is 1/2 the
circumference and the length of this arc
is 1/4 the circumference now look at
this circle consider a part of the area
of the circle what will be the length of
this green arc it's unclear you cannot
guess the length just by looking at the
figure so there has to be something that
defines the length of the arc the length
of the arc is directly proportional to
the angle it subtends at the center the
first arc subtends an angle of 180
degrees at the center the entire
circumference subtends an angle of 360
degrees at the center so the length of
the arc is given by 180 by 360
multiplied by 2 pi r in simple words
we can say that the ark has covered 180
degrees of the total 360 degrees this
can be reduced to half multiplied by two
PI R you will understand better with
this second example this arc subtends an
angle of 90 degrees at the center so
it's length will be 90 by 360 multiplied
by 2 PI R now what will be the length of
this arc if the angle subtended by it is
30 degrees
it will be 30 by 360 x 2 PI R we can say
that the angle subtended by the arc at
the center is a part of the angle
covered by the entire circle which is
360 degrees so if we have to generalize
it we can say that if the angle
subtended by the arc at the centre is
Theta then the length of the arc is
Theta divided by 360 multiplied by 2 pi
R
you